NEED TO GET TO THE TRUTH THIS
TIME, AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW IT'S REACTION
FORMER U.S. ATTORNEY JOE
DiGENOVA, JIM JORDAN, AND
ROBERT RAY, IT DOESN'T GET
BETTER THAN THIS TONIGHT.
WHAT DOES THE IMPRESSIVE SCOPE
OF THIS NEW PROBE TELL US
TONIGHT?
>> JAMES COMEY, BRENNAN, AND
CLAPPER HAVE SAID TO THEMSELVES
WHICH ONE OF US IS GOING TO PAY
THE BARR BILL.
THE BARR BILL IS COMING DUE.
THEY ALREADY OCCURRED MEETINGS
BETWEEN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
CIA DIRECTOR AND DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE HAVE NOW
FOCUSED ON A LASER THAT THE CORE
OF THIS CONSPIRACY BEGAN WITH
JOHN BRENNAN AND ENDS WITH JOHN
BRENNAN IN LONDON AND D.C. AND
THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE.
THIS IS SERIOUS BUSINESS AND FOR
THE FIRST TIME, I NOW BELIEVE
THAT SOME OF THESE GUYS ARE
GOING TO GO TO PRISON.
>> Laura: WOW, YOU'VE
MENTIONED BRENNAN AND
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN, WE GOT SOME
PROFOUND SOUND FROM BOTH BRENNAN
AND KLAPPER.
THIS WAS BRENDAN TODAY
EXPLAINING WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
THIS NEW PROBE, LET'S WATCH.
>> IT WENT THROUGH A RIGOROUS
DUE PROCESS, IT WAS APPROVED BY
THE FISA COURT, IT WENT THROUGH
ALL OF THOSE STEPS AND WHAT THEY
ARE TRYING TO DO IS UNCOVER
SOMETHING THEY WILL MISREPRESENT
AS BEING PART OF HIS DEEP STATE
EFFORT TO TRY TO UNDERMINE
DONALD TRUMP SELECTION.
>> Laura: IT WAS ALL COPACETIC
COPACETIC.
IT WENT TO THE FISA COURT,
INVESTIGATING THE INVESTIGATORS.
>> HE USED THE TERM
MISREPRESENTATION, IT'S WHAT
THEY DID WITH THE DOSSIER.
THEY DIDN'T TELL THE COURT WHO
PAID, --
>> Laura: HOW SERIOUS THIS?
>> I THINK THIS IS VERY SERIOUS
AND BILL BARR DOING WHAT HE
SAID.
WHEN HE WAS IN FRONT OF THE
SENATE FINANCE COMMITTEE HE SAID
HE WAS SERIOUS ABOUT PUTTING
TOGETHER A TEAM TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS.
THERE WAS FOUR KEY THINGS, THERE
WAS A FAILURE OF LEADERSHIP AT
THE FBI.
HE SAID SPYING TOOK PLACE, THERE
IS A BASIS FOR HIS CONCERNED
ABOUT THE SPYING THAT OCCURRED
AND HE USED TWO TERMS THAT
SHOULD SCARE EVERY SINGLE
AMERICAN.
HE SAID UNAUTHORIZED
SURVEILLANCE AND POLITICAL
SURVEILLANCE, THOSE THINGS ARE
NOT SUPPOSED TO HAPPEN.
>> Laura: THAT'S WHAT CHINA
DOES, THIS IS WHAT CHINA DOES
AND RUSSIA DOES, ROBERT RAY I'VE
GOT TO GET YOU IN ON THIS.
THEY ACCUSE TRUMP OF SPOONING
WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN TO GET
ELECTED AND YET THEY USE
AUTOCRATIC DICTATORIAL MEANS TO
SURVEILLED THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN TO
GET THE INFORMATION THEY CLAIMED
WAS GOING TO BE THERE.
NOW WE HAVE THE DNI INVOLVED AND
THE CIA INVOLVED WITH A MAN AS
SERIOUS AS BILL BARR, HE WAS NOT
COWED ONE BIT BY WHAT THEY TRY
TO DO TO HIM LAST WEEK.
>> CONGRESSMAN JORDAN IS RIGHT,
THIS ISN'T A QUESTION OF WHETHER
THE PROCEDURAL STEPS WERE
FOLLOWED, THIS IS A QUESTION OF
EXPLORING BIAS AND WHETHER THAT
HAD AN IMPACT ON WHAT WAS OR
WASN'T DISCLOSED TO THE FISA
COURT.
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, IT'S A
SERIOUS ISSUE.
THERE'S A CASE IN THE
SUPREME COURT ABOUT THIS, FRANKS
VERSUS DELAWARE.
ALL PROSECUTORS AND AGENTS ARE
FAMILIAR WITH IT AND IT'S A
SERIOUS QUESTION NOW THAT IS
GOING TO BE EXPLORED BY A
PROSECUTOR.
THIS IS NOT DUPLICATIVE OF
MICHAEL HOROWITZ'S INVESTIGATION
BECAUSE THE IG DOESN'T HAVE
PROSECUTORIAL AUTHORITY TO BRING
CHARGES.
IN THIS INSTANCE IT'S THE RESULT
OF BILL BARR'S APPOINTMENT,
THERE IS GOING TO BE ON
INVESTIGATION, THE PURPOSE OF
WHICH IS TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT ANY CRIMES WERE COMMITTED
WHICH IS JOE DiGENOVA'S POINT.
>> Laura: CRIMES COMMITTED --
THIS IS NOW EXPLAINING WHY THEY
THREW SO MUCH MUD AT A MAN LIKE
BILL BARR, WITH THE HISTORY AND
REPUTATION HE HAS.
WHAT'S THE MOST DANGEROUS,
SOMEONE WHO HAS SOMETHING TO
LOSE?
HE MADE A LOT OF MONEY, HE
DIDN'T NEED THIS JOB.
>> HOROWITZ HAS ALREADY
CONCLUDED THAT THE FINAL THREE
FISAS WERE COMPLETELY ILLEGAL.
IF HE'S NOW ON THE BRINK OF
FINDING THE FIRST FISA WAS
COMPLETELY ILLEGAL.
THEY'VE ALREADY USED A GRAND
JURY IN CONNECTICUT, HE'S
ALREADY TALKED TO THE INTEL
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: HOW LONG HAS THIS
BEEN GOING ON?
>> DURHAM HAS BEEN WORKING FOR A
COUPLE OF MONTHS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS, THIS IS
NOW BIG TIME.
THIS IS WHERE BRENNAN NEEDS FIVE
LAWYERS.
>> Laura: ARE THEY LAWYERED
UP?
>> I HOPE COMEY HAS SOMETHING
OTHER THAN MR. RICHMOND TO WHOM
HE LEAKED HIS MEMOS.
>> Laura: ISN'T PATRICK
FITZGERALD?
>> NOTHING LIKE A SLEAZY
PROSECUTOR.
>> Laura: HORRIBLE PROSECUTOR.
>> THAT'S THE U.S. ATTORNEY WHO
WAS ALSO LOOKING INTO JIM BAKER,
THAT'S WHERE THE INVESTIGATION
WAS TAKING PLACE.
IF THAT'S WHO BILL BARR SELECTED
AND IT'S NOT JUST THE DOSSIER,
REMEMBER WHAT WE LEARNED TWO
WEEKS AGO.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTED
THE FBI TOOK SOMEONE POSING AS
SOMEONE ELSE, THOSE ARE TWO
CASES WHERE SOMETHING TOOK
PLACE.
>> Laura: WE ALSO HAVE TO PLAY
BERNIE SANDERS WHO WAS OUT THERE
TONIGHT, I WANT TO PLAY GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS FIRST AND GET YOU
AND RAY AND JOE TO TALK ABOUT
IT, LET'S WATCH.
>> I FLY TO GREECE, I HAVE DOGS
SNIFFING FOR MONEY, I'M ARRESTED
IN DULLES WITH AGENTS RUMMAGING
THROUGH MY BAGS LOOKING FOR
MONEY.
CLEARLY THIS WAS SOME SORT OF
STING OPERATION AND BY THE TIME
IT HAPPENED THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
WAS APPOINTED.
>> Laura: THEY WERE DANGLING
MONEY AT HIM, THEY ALL KNEW HOW
THIS WAS ALL GOING TO GO.
THIS WAS ALL ROLLED OUT
ACCORDING TO PLAN.
>> THEY PUT SOMEBODY POSING AS
SOMEBODY ELSE WITH GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS AND STARTED ASKING
ALL OF THESE QUESTIONS EARLY ON
IN THIS INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: THAT IS WHAT KICKED
IT ALL OFF, SUPPOSEDLY.
>> BACK IN JULY OF 2016.
BILL BARR HAS SAID HE'S GOING TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT, THAT IS
A GOOD THING, LET'S GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS SO THAT NOTHING
LIKE THIS -- IF EVERYTHING THAT
WE THINK HAPPEN DID, THIS SHOULD
NOT HAPPEN IN THE UNITED STATES.
>> Laura: WE STILL HAVEN'T
GOTTEN TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL SCANDAL.
I'VE GOT TO PLAY THIS,
BERNIE SANDERS HAD THIS TO SAY
ABOUT THE LAUNCH OF THE NEW
INVESTIGATION.
>> TRUMP DOES ALL OF THE TIME,
HE TRIES TO DIVERT ATTENTION
FROM THE REALITIES OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH THE WHITE HOUSE OR HIS
CAMPAIGN.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT, WHAT THE FBI
DID IS THEY HAD REASON TO
BELIEVE THAT THERE WAS COLLUSION
AND THEY INVESTIGATED THAT
COLLUSION.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD BE
INVESTIGATING THE INVESTIGATORS.
>> Laura: OF COURSE NOT, IF
THE SHOE WAS ON THE OTHER FOOT
HE WOULD BE DOING A CANDLELIGHT
VIGIL NOW.
AS A FORMER INDEPENDENT COUNSEL
DO YOU AGREE WITH BERNIE?
>> THE PRESIDENT'S RIGHT AT THE
CONCLUSION OF THE INVESTIGATION,
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION IS
OVER TO WONDER HOW WE GOT ON
THIS PATH TO START WITH.
ISN'T THAT AN APPROPRIATE
QUESTION TO ASK?
I'M NOT GOING TO PREJUDGE THE
OUTCOME.
UNLIKE DEMOCRATS THERE'S NO
POINT IN SINGING ABOUT WHAT MAY,
OR WHAT PROSECUTIONS MAY UNFOLD.
CLEARLY IT WARRANTED A SECOND
LOOK, THAT WAS WHY THERE WAS AN
IG INVESTIGATION AND NOW THE
HANDOFF IS COMPLETE.
IT'S NOW IN THE HANDS OF A
PROSECUTOR WITH PROSECUTORIAL
AUTHORITY WHO WILL MAKE A
DECISION ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
ANY CRIMES WERE COMMITTED AND
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S APPROPRIATE
TO BRING CHARGES AGAINST THOSE
WHO WERE RESPONSIBLE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU EXPECT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO DO.
>> Laura: NOT SIGN OFF ON
PHONY DOSSIERS.
>> BILL BARR SAID IT'S A BIG
DEAL.
>> Laura: LIBERALS USED TO
CARE ABOUT CIVIL LIBERTIES, NO
MATTER WHOSE CIVIL LIBERTIES
WERE BEING TREAD UPON -- TROD
UPON?
AND Q, JOE.
I HAVE TO CHECK MY GRAMMAR.
THIS DON JR. DEAL, THEY CUT SOME
DEAL FOR HIM TO TESTIFY, RICHARD
BURR, WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> I WOULD'VE TOLD THEM TO STICK
IT.
>> WHAT'S GOING ON NOW WITH THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE WITH
RICHARD BURR WHO IS A DISGUSTING
REPUBLICAN CHAIRMAN, THE PHONY
REPUBLICAN FROM NORTH CAROLINA.
DON JR. HAS EVERY RIGHT TO
BELIEVE WHAT'S HAPPENING IS
ABUSIVE AND     AN END VINDICTIV
ABUSIVE AND     AN END VINDICTI,
ABUSIVE AND     AN END VINDICTIN
ABUSIVE AND     AN END VINDICTIO
CITIZEN HAS TO TAKE THAT.
THEY CAN IN STOMACH INVOKE THE
FIFTH AMENDMENT.
>> THEY ARE CALLING HIM BACK
BASED ON THE TESTIMONY OF A GUY
WHO WENT TO PRISON FOR LYING TO
CONGRESS, WHEN HE CAME IN FRONT
OF THE COMMITTEE, HE LIED SEVEN